how did a gangster use kung fu movies to
launder money and how did a bruce lee
look alike end up fighting dracula
these are the wildest true stories from
martial arts films of the 70s and the
80s
to many casual fans of the genre bruce
lee is the alpha and omega of 70's era
martial art cinema but there were plenty
of other martial arts performers who
scored substantial screen hits in their
native countries and the united states
well at least before bruce lee broke
into the mainstream with 1971's the big
boss among these breakout actors was
taiwanese performer wang yu you starred
in the early shaw brothers hit the
one-armed swordsman he also helped to
shift asian action films from wushia
movies to blood-soaked brawl fests by
writing directing and starring in the
chinese boxer in 1970. a year later
another taiwan native chinese opera
school student angela mao signed with
golden harvest the production company of
ex-shaw brothers exec raymond chao she
would play the lead role in numerous
features including lady kung fu and lady
whirlwind mao displayed astonishingly
athletic fight skills in her films many
choreographed by jackie chan
collaborator and future u.s tv star samo
hong both mao and wang yu remain popular
stars in the asian and u.s markets for
several years
however their successes were
overshadowed by lee's brief yet meteoric
rise even though mao would play lee's
doomed sister and enter the dragon wong
yu moved on to increasingly smaller
pictures and suffered a string of
personal setbacks before returning to
movies for a short period of time in the
2000s mao meanwhile left acting in the
early 1980s and oversaw several
taiwanese restaurants in new york city
one of the primary through lines in the
book these fists break bricks is the
connection between martial arts and the
black community inner city black youths
embraced both the self-defense
disciplines and the movies themselves
the book detailed the lives and careers
of early black martial arts champs like
victor moore sijo muhammad owen watson
and dennis brown all of whom faced
personal and professional challenges
throughout their lives as co-author
grady hendricks explained karate
champion victor moore couldn't compete
in whites only venues
in spite of how thoroughly entrenched
the martial arts were in the black
community black martial artists faced a
number of struggles jim kelly cut a fly
figure and entered the dragon but he
found it impossible to find career
traction otherwise outside of low budget
fair like the tattoo connection on the
powerfully built and charming ron van
cleef hendrix elaborated he never had a
single movie produced by a major studio
finding all his work on indie
productions black dragon's revenge saw
van cleef paired with skilled latino
martial artist charles bonet the puerto
rican panther as bonet was known also
struggled to land movie work and later
wound up temporarily homeless he also
struggled with drug addiction before
gaining sobriety and stability with the
help of his former students black
martial arts stars in the 80s and 90s
didn't fare much better tymac bariello a
student of ron van cleef came from
nowhere to capture the lead in the barry
gordy produced the last dragon only to
see stardom ripped away when subsequent
film deals fell through
billy blanks who started numerous
low-budget kickboxing movies found
greater fame as creator of the tybo
cardio program today a handful of black
martial arts stars enjoy varying degrees
of fame including michael jai white
sebastien fucon and stunt performers
latif crowder aaron tony and bobby
samuels
the popular myth surrounding bruce lee
is that he was a success in everything
he attempted from martial arts to movies
in both hong kong and america but the
truth is as hendrix shares is very
different hendrix had this to say about
the legendary martial artist when bruce
lee went back to hong kong to appear in
some low-budget kung fu movies he was a
washed-up former child actor and
see-less television star leah stint as a
young actor in hong kong dramas ended
shortly before he relocated with his
family to the united states in 1959 his
impressive physical feats at martial
arts tournaments led to a screen test
for batman producer william dozier who
cast him as cato in the green hornet tv
series when the show was cancelled after
a single season lee went on to teach
martial arts to actors like steve
mcqueen and james coburn while waiting
for his big u.s break it never came so
he returned to hong kong to star in a
low budget action film for golden
harvest that film
1971's the big boss became the highest
grossing film in hong kong history until
its follow-up fist of fury broke its
record the overwhelming success of these
two films would stand as a testament to
lee's captivating on-screen presence and
powerful performances
after establishing himself as a global
star with films like way of the dragon
which featured a pre-stardom chuck
norris lee began working on enter the
dragon
the film was lee's first u.s hong kong
co-production but the legendary actor
sadly passed away four weeks before its
release in 1973.
historian chris pajali writes
bruce lee worked so hard for so long to
become a movie star that his sudden and
premature death at age 32 left his
growing number of fans wanting more than
just four completed films
though enter the dragon was lee's final
completed movie the heavily edited cult
classic game of death was his final film
project written produced and directed by
and starring lee the film nevertheless
became one of the first bruce playtation
flicks that emerged after the actor's
death
following his passing a plethora of
cheap bruce lee imitators jumped in to
fill the massive void in the genre that
bruce left behind
hong kong film companies including
golden harvest immediately began
cranking out films to capitalize on
lee's fame the bruce ploitation
sub-genre can be broken down into three
types of films the first type is the
biopic which employs a mix of
reenactment footage with the real league
to tell the story of the martial arts
icon the second type are spin-offs in
which bruce lee not only lives but also
becomes a mythical hero battling
gangsters mad scientists and in the
berserk the dragon lives again faux
versions of james bond the man with no
name and even dracula listen dracula
your zombies can't help you
all with popeye as a sidekick the third
sub-genre sequels features threadbare
follow-ups to lee's biggest hits actors
from bruce's original films such as
shikiyan and bolo young from enter the
dragon would often appear alongside the
bruce copycats producers tapped a host
of actors from indonesia taiwan japan
and south korea to play the new bruces
these actors were renamed with creative
monikers such as bruce lee with an i
instead of two e's bruce lee bruce leong
bronson lee dragonly and even myron
bruce lee taste and logic rarely
mattered in bruce ploitation films in
fist of fear touch of death footage from
lee's childhood films is awkwardly
shoehorned into a baffling plot about
the search for the next bruce lee all of
this is anchored by footage from a real
martial arts bout in madison square
garden fake street fights with ron van
cleef and an outrageous narration about
bruce's samurai grandfather bruce's
great grandfather was one of china's
greatest samurai master swordsman of the
19th century
the demand for bruce lee movies or any
footage of bruce lee on film for that
matter led distributors to get creative
case in point larry joachim a new york
based distributor who specialized in
weekend matinees for kids among his most
successful titles was the 1966 batman
film starring adam west
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb
the success of batman sparked an idea
from joachim's son marco marco recalled
that batman producer william dozier had
also overseen the green hornet with
bruce lee being a die-hard kung fu movie
fan himself marco suggested to his
father that money could be made from the
old series larry used his connections
with fox to wrangle some 16 millimeter
prints of green hornet which he turned
over to marco marco then watched the
prince and assembled a rough cut that
combined footage of lee from the
episodes into a semblance of a new story
the completed film entitled the green
hornet opened in 1974 and grossed 45 000
in five days
enough footage from the green hornet was
left over for a sequel called fury of
the dragon which was released in 1976
and played in theaters for a decade
these films remain two of the most
lucrative and widely distributed
examples of what would be referred to
today as a
fan edit
there were a number of colorful film
industry figures distributing martial
arts films in the 1970s however
georgia-based michael thieves took the
colorful label to new heights or depths
as it were
in 1973 this scored a modest box office
hit after acquiring the rights to a 1971
taiwanese film starring wang yu called
the desperate chase which he retitled
blood of the dragon it was believed at
the time that this was an affluent music
producer from atlanta who made his foray
into distributing kung fu films
but after the fbi hit him with charges
of pornography and arson he gained a
reputation as a violent pornographer
using film distribution as a means of
laundering his money this was making
millions by overseeing his own peepshow
booth empire and wasn't above killing a
few people who stood in his way he even
went as far as placing a pipe bomb in
the car of a rival businessman thieves
went to prison in 1974 but used his
connections to georgia congressman
andrew young to secure transfer to a
minimum security prison in indiana from
which he escaped in 1978. after
murdering roger underhill a former
associate who had turned informant to
testify against him in 1978 thieves
earned a spot on the fbi's most wanted
list his time in the spotlight was brief
however the feds busted him for trying
to withdraw cash under a false identity
he even earned additional convictions
while serving a life sentence for
telling fellow inmates about the murders
he'd committed davis died in prison in
2013.
as with all film trends the first wave
of kung fu movies eventually wound down
in the 70s but not before the release of
one of the most outrageous asian action
films ever produced a 1974 article about
yakuza movies in film comment convinced
newline cinema president robert shea
that the next big martial arts picture
might come from japan instead of hong
kong a visit to tokyo's toei company did
yield a gangster movie called the
tattooed hitman but shea also spotted a
poster for an action thriller featuring
actor shinichi chiba shay screened the
film and was floored by chiba's near
maniacal anti-hero and astonishingly
violent set pieces especially one
particularly memorable scene featuring
the screen image turning x-ray to reveal
the full devastation of a fist crushing
a man's skull with ease shae bought the
rights to the film and gave it to
filmmaker jack shoulder for an english
language cut shoulder retitled it the
street fighter and dubbed its star sonny
chiba the mpaa slapped the street
fighter with an x rating for violence
which revolted most critics but
audiences flocked to the film and made
it a box office hit
new line released two sequels return of
the street fighter and the street
fighter's last revenge along with a
related film sister street fighter
featuring chiba and atsuko su-shihomi
other companies such as aquarius
releasing snatched up more cheaper
titles like the bodyguard to further
feed his fan base chiba who was not a
big fan of the street fighter himself
remained active in dozens of japanese
and us action films for decades chiba
tragically passed away from
complications of kovan 19 in 2021
there was a feeling that the martial
arts boom was beginning to tap out in
the mid-1970s as a result producers fell
back on another tried and true method of
bringing audiences back to theaters
folding kung fu into other genres
cross-pollination produced some
memorable experiments within the martial
arts genre jackie chan and samuel
samuhung scored big hits by folding
comedy into action but efforts to merge
kung fu with other genres weren't as
successful shaw brothers saw mixed
results by co-producing the stranger and
the gunfighter
the film was a martial arts spaghetti
western with lee van cleef and lolita
from five fingers of death shaw also
partnered with the uk's hammer studios
for the horror kung fu hybrid the legend
of the seven golden vampires from there
the mashups only got more dire shaw
teamed with warner brothers for the
blaxploitation action thriller cleopatra
jones and the casino of gold and enter
the dragon star jim kelly was stranded
in crummy martial arts sci-fi spy
oddities like death dimension efforts to
release kung fu in 3d such as the
taiwanese films revenge of the shogun
woman and dynasty only yielded minor
returns in the states chris pajali one
of the authors of the book these fists
break bricks sums up the genre hybrids
succinctly mixing martial arts with
comedy and horror seemed natural in hong
kong productions but attempts to combine
kung fu with other fading genres like
black's plantation and spaghetti
westerns even when the hybrids were
entertaining mostly came across like
acts of desperation
in the world that existed prior to the
internet it was much easier to pass
fiction off as the truth most people
simply had no viable way of verifying
claims and kung fu film distributors at
the time were all too willing to take
advantage of people's ignorance many
exploitation outfits weren't above
playing fast and loose with the facts
about titles the bruce ploitation
sub-genre is a perfect example as is the
practice of attributing fake awards to
their films and stars like the ebony
fist award won by playboy playmate jean
bell of tnt jackson the deadly knives
aka fists of vengeance never won karate
film of the year and china's grand
master of kung fu chiang ming li didn't
endorse iron fists because neither the
award nor the men are real sleazy film
distributors were always eager to
exploit new trends to promote their
movies this would often mean retitling
kung fu films to resemble contemporary
box office winners these included
chinese godfather kung fu exorcist and
kung fu halloween just to name a few
another entertaining trend was the
announcement of movie projects that
never existed the fact that no script
director or funding was in place didn't
stop boston-based producer distributor
seraphim keralexus from announcing enter
three dragons nor did it prevent ads
promoting the release of elsa meets
bruce lee in the devil's triangle that
picture would have brought together
diane thorne star of the infamous elsa
she-wolf on the ss and a bruce imitator
for some wacky hijinks unfortunately for
exploitation fans the ad is the only
element of the film that actually
exists
jackie chan's early career path was
pretty similar to bruce lee's both men
started out as child actors and chan
even worked as a stuntman and minor
player in lee's fist of fury and entered
the dragon after working his way up to
stunt choreographer jackie was tapped by
producer director lo wei to imitate
bruce in new fists of fury a phony
sequel to bruce's breakout feature
jackie later found his groove with
comedy action hybrids like 1978's
drunken master which led to his
ascension as a leading man after parting
ways with lil way jackie moved to golden
harvest where he created many of the
jaw-dropping action films that made him
a martial arts legend
just as bruce lee's success generated
the bruce platation scene jackie's
popularity spawned a similar explosion
of imposters doing their best to ape the
kung fu star's signature style of
comedic action chief among them were
indonesia's willie dozen also known as
billy chong and ulysses zen
also on the chan train korean actor
zhang jin wang who sported the
incredible pseudonym of elton chong in
one of the most perfectly reductive
mashups of all time the 1981 south
korean film jackie and bruce to the
rescue featured impersonators of both
bruce lee and jackie chan
theatrical screenings of martial arts
movies took a flurry of roundhouse kicks
in the early 1980s changing audience
tastes headlines linking kung fu to real
life violence and the collapse of the
grindhouse theater circuits eliminated
many of the venues that played asian
action films mel marin of cinema shares
and world northal kept many older titles
in circulation through black belt
theater packages for television but if
you wanted to see the latest martial
arts movies in the 80s your choices were
limited your only options were going to
chinese language theaters in big cities
to see the new jackie chan titles
ponying up exorbitant fees for video
cassettes or settling for the action
stylings of chuck norris
norris operated on the fringes of the
film industry throughout the early 70s
including a face-off against his friend
bruce lee in way of the dragon however
he vaulted to leading man status with a
string of low budget action films
beginning in 1977 with breaker breaker
from there he enjoyed box office success
that extended into the early 1980s
attention from major studios soon
followed as did a second wave of stardom
for norris as a mainstream star in films
like missing in action of course once
norse's character started focusing more
on guns than kicks someone had to take
his place many of these would-be heroes
were cut from the same cloth as norris
young white men with martial arts
backgrounds like kickboxing champion joe
lewis lauren avadon and kurt mckenny
each got a shot at kung fu stardom in
films like mckinney in no retreat no
surrender and avadon in king of the
kickboxers but they were quickly
supplanted by a new crop of stars many
of whom shared the screen with them in
supporting roles
this era produced a few more
recognizable names pojolli wrote in
these fists break bricks
it wasn't until the close of the 80s
when solid box office straws like
jean-claude van damme and steven seagal
filled the void left by norris while
cynthia rothrock billy blanks and don
the dragon wilson became direct to video
action attractions
martial arts found a comfortable second
home on vhs in the 1980s older or
obscure titles gained new audiences
through vhs releases and the demand for
new material gave acting and directing
hopefuls a shot at making and releasing
their dream projects it seemed like
anything that was feature-length and
somewhat confidently produced could make
money in the home video market that's
that's great mister really it's that's
just what i needed
many of these home-grown efforts came
from places outside of hollywood
missouri-based detective and martial
arts instructor ron white threw down a
little over twelve thousand dollars to
make 1985's justice ninja style in which
he starred as a small town ninja jun
chung who starred in bruce lee fights
back from the grave made several ultra
low budget ninja picks including la
street fighters which featured the 41
year old chong as a high school gang
leader chuck mcneil directed a slew of
home movie style action films like
dragon spade and dragon from the east
though the actual existence of several
of his films is unclear despite
challenges and critics these regional
filmmakers remain undaunted
wrote in these fist break bricks they
delivered low budget cult classics like
the chicken obsessed furious and grand
master yk kim's ninja rific the miami
connection and oddities like wichita's
king kung fu about an escaped kung fu
fighting gorilla who abducts a pizza hut
waitress and skills the tallest holiday
inn in town
the ninja craze in the united states was
at full spin in 1985. the teenage mutant
ninja turtles had just burst out of the
sewers and onto the scene toy stores
were packed to the brim with remco's
ninja strike force action figures and
ninjas were the cutting edge of fashion
for halloween that year ninjas had been
on the sideline of movies and television
for decades like in the 1967 bond
feature you only lived twice it was the
release of eric van lusbader's 1980
novel the ninja that sparked mainstream
interest in all things stealthy and
japanese
this newly stoked interest in the
clandestine warriors brought about canon
films enter the ninja in 1980 which
featured franco nero the original django
of spaghetti western fame playing a
ninja doing battle against an evil
businessman few found nero believable in
the role but the top ras at canon films
found a new star in show kosuji who
played an evil ninja a martial arts
teacher and minor actor in bruce
ploytation films kosiji briefly became
the go-to on-screen ninja in the 1980s
still his early showcases for canon were
underwhelming or in the case of ninja 3
the domination downright bizarre he
parted ways with the company in the
mid-80s to oversee his own films for
trans world entertainment including the
box office hit pray for death
canon films rebounded with american
ninja a vehicle intended for chuck
norris which instead became a
star-making project for formal model
michael darkoff
dukkhaff stars is a rather conspicuous
white guy who just so happens to find
out he is descended from a long line of
ninja masters this ludicrous effort was
followed by four more american ninja
titles regardless of how off the rails
some ninja films were getting ninjas
retained their hold on martial arts fans
and pop culture through toys costumes
and video games through the early 1990s
in a sub-genre where plot cohesion often
took a backseat to smoke bombs and
color-coordinated costumes the ninja
films of director godfrey ho stand out
as some of the most confusing
haphazardly made titles in the martial
arts genre
[Music]
hoe cut his filmmaking teeth at shaw
brothers before teaming with producers
joseph lai and thomas tang of
intercontinental film distributors or
ifd together they went on to crank out
dozens of low-budget action films in
international markets that were largely
ignored by other hong kong filmmakers
the success of enter the ninja spurred
ifd to produce their own ninja films
many starred american actor richard
harrison who had been a major player in
italian westerns and spy films in the
1960s it didn't matter that harrison had
no apparent martial arts abilities the
full-body ninja costumes allowed for
extensive use of body doubles during
action scenes even though harrison
technically appeared in four ifd ninja
films including 1984's scorpion
thunderbolt he later learned that ho had
edited footage of him into at least a
dozen additional ninja films each more
baffling than the last hendrix wrote of
ho in these fists break bricks he always
wanted more more ninjas more explosions
more everything as he said to his actors
i can't see her acting more acting ifd
later turned its attention from ninjas
to kickboxing after the success of
canon's bloodsport starring jean-claude
van damme ho later parted ways with his
ift partners and worked in films with
cynthia rothrock among others all while
enjoying cult status among fans of truly
bizarre cinema
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
martial arts movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]